this episode brought to you by
stamps.com why go to the store to get
stamps when you can have them printed
right at home for your convenience
[Music]
hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember so you don't have to well it's
around Easter time and you know what
that means
a lot of movies about a certain furry
Longyear buck-toothed bunny rabbit who
has a thing for eggs I'm of course
talking about Jesus yeah this is the
time when a lot of Christ's film start
making the rounds the funny thing about
Jesus movies before they actually became
funny things is when it comes to
Christmas they're usually shared with
other Christmas type movies you know
about Santa Claus or family togetherness
or helping the poor and hungry get work
but that's not how Easter works Easter
is prominently Jesus's cinematic time to
shine whether for better or Gibson don't
really have a problem with this as a lot
of these movies hold up pretty well many
of them cinematic classics but it is
strange that one of the most popular
holiday mascots doesn't have many
cinematic movies about it there's plenty
of TV specials and maybe an occasional
appearance here are there some more
falls to the law insane than others
note to self must add to queue button to
her films based on one of our favorite
Breaking and Entering icons are
surprisingly far in few what I'm not
putting up with it anymore that's why
today we're going on our own Easter
bunny adventure hey critic carrot juice
what in the world as the official mascot
of Easter I decided to hand over my
Easter juice to you you mean you've been
the Easter Bunny all this time that's
right and I've chosen you to continue on
the tradition me just sound way I can't
possibly be the Easter Bunny can I come
on critic I'll take you to my factory
oh but carrot juice however will we get
to the Easter factory for this our
studio through the magic of magic doors
[Music]
come on critic we gotta get you ready to
be the ultimate Easter Bunny well I'm
sure I'm gonna have some slip-ups along
the way but if I only believe in myself
I know I can not only save Easter but
also have some hilarious hijinks along
the way now let's hop to it critic so
aren't you gonna like show me how to use
magic and make candy and stuff
no you're mostly just sit around while I
tell you what not to do oh don't do that
oh no don't do that either
did I say you could breathe hmm
you might be right something's missing
oh I know your flannel shirt it wouldn't
be a cool Easter movie without your
flannel shirt there now your hip and
remember keep smiling not that much it's
this all we're gonna do we're just gonna
sit around a room while you tell me
things not to do of course not oh well
that's nice I cut to something
disappointing is we're gonna sit in a
car while I tell you what not to do I
see no whimsy in this this is whimsy
less
we've got your flannel shirt and do you
know how to play the drums not really
oh we're gonna believe the drums you're
the Easter Bunny for God's sake what
does any of this have to do with Easter
I don't know but it made hop a ton of
money
what is hop in the back seat or know
what we're doing yeah no we're doing
[Music]
[Applause]
the 2011 illumination film hop was a big
hit at the box office and continues to
be one of the dominant Easter movies
whenever the subject is brought up just
Google Easter movie and it's literally
the first film to appear there's a few
reasons for this one it was a big-budget
Easter Bunny movie - it was well
advertised Easter Bunny movie 3 it is
the only Easter Bunny movie at least
with a big budget and was well
advertised many families rent this bowl
of rabbit droppings confusing it for
cocoa puffs and convince themselves
they're enjoying chocolate when really
the swallowing shit it lacks any kind of
imagination Wonder and creativity that
will be associated with such a timeless
icon so of course we're gonna look at it
here today so let's see if their magical
world of the Easter Bunny is anything
like the real magical world of the
Easter Bunny remember critic keep
smiling and learn to play the drums I
gotta kiss my rocket sleigh back home
wait didn't you see it travel via magic
door like we'd put our a material in
this script way this is hop so how long
before there's an egg pun in this movie
literally the first frame even egghead
needs a few moments to set up not even a
minute in and we already have bunny
boobies and I expected more from the
director of Garfield to Alvin and the
Chipmunks and grumpy cat's worst
Christmas Oh God we've got a thought we
get a brief glance of the Easter bunnies
of the past and I already wanna know
more about them than the thumper
equivalent of quack pack stop taking
notes Disney oh I'm still gonna make it
we see one of our leads is named Fred
played by thank God I went to that
Westworld audition james marsden who
introduces the idea that he is somehow
the next Easter Bunny hi I'm Fred O'Hare
the first human Easter Bunny sounds
insane you say well hold a rally at
Charlottesville you anti human garbage
again - the film's credit this is kind
of an inventive idea a human being as an
Easter Bunny has a lot of possibilities
and even with the lame puns setting of
Easter Island get it because Christmas
the credits open with a lot of creative
imagery showing how preparing for Easter
works
hot fudge sprinkles whipped cream no
things I don't think we're gonna top
this the cunt Easter Bunny shows his son
EB what's in store for his future he's
voiced by Hugh Laurie which just
reinforces that this is Arthur Christmas
if it's balls were cut off by Peter
Rabbit and hey this is an elimination
movie should there be some a matches
dick doughnut hole stealing way too much
screen time do not have real a bird
under the yoke of the pony's tyranny how
do you think they come up with these
inspired comedic designs
yo dot put a face on it brilliant orange
dot put a face on it brilliant yellow
dot again put a face on it brilliant
much Maj marina follow this is Carlos a
HISP tallien voiced by Hank Azaria foggy
type son live in mr. we'll be clear
senator young well start making this
poster you know we got to deal with this
movie in the near future Carlos doesn't
like the white rabbit privileged and
thinks he should be in charge but that's
not important right now is the Easter
Bunny starts his deliveries around the
world
so that's why dad told me to stay out of
the medicine cabinet years later the boy
grows up into james marsden playing a
man named Fred O'Hare his brother Bucky
has some stories he apparently still
lives at home with his family
how'd that job interview go don't know
if it's really what I'm looking for
did they pay money then it's exactly
what you've been looking for look II
keep dying in franchises you need backup
employment but it turns out this is an
intervention by his family to try and
kick him out and get a real job ah
reminds me of dinners at my home you
need to get a life you need to get a job
and you need to move out sometimes I
think you adopted me because fred was
such a disappointment huh it's like the
ice door only somehow more depressing at
the same time EP has grown up into
everybody's favorite well somebody's
favorite hair quad Russell Brand
actually does a passable job as this
character but whose voice is so
recognizable you can't help but imagine
what the real Russell Brand would say in
a lot of these scenarios note that don't
want to be the Easter Bunny you're about
to be crowned the Easter Bunny in front
of 3,000 of your peers when I was a
crack and heroin addict I made some
unusual decisions they included dressing
in an inappropriate way on September the
11th now before I talk about this
remember I was on crack and heroin
Phoebe doesn't want to be the Easter
Bunny because of the pressure of being
too perfect
again Russell Brand was cast in this
role so he's clearly not gonna achieve
that so he finds a way through a magical
door to Hollywood where Fred gets done
packing his emotional baggage you should
know they did adopt your younger sister
because they were ashamed of you his
older sister gives him a lead to a good
job at a nearby mansion while EP looks
for a place to stay at the Playboy House
God these fossil brand jokes really do
write themselves don't they let's never
destroy a marriage unless you're really
bored pop yourself down nominate see if
we can't get you pregnant
Phoebe literally bumped into Fred who
realizes there's only one way to put him
and the audience out of its misery don't
you worry little friend I'm gonna end
your suffering
ha remember when your dad hit that cute
animal kids now you know this also
probably happened Oh Phoebe talks and
Frank can't believe his agent I mean
eyes who said that
your latest victim I could just maybe
come with you for a couple of months you
know why I can't take this money
seriously outside of that he looks so
generic and uninteresting I keep
expecting him to sell me car insurance
at any moment so if you want to save 15%
by switching to Geico do the gecko dance
down to your nearest location here's a
talking hamburger the animator did in
his spare time I'm gonna get my own
movie and/or TV show too he is no no
don't go in the x-mansion only Wolverine
is there and he hates you
[Music]
I'm a B and G ah EB explains that he's
hungry but Fred doesn't know what to
feed him is there something you'd rather
eat you weird little thing well do you
want to eat rabbit Fred tries to get rid
of them but EB tries playing up a guilt
trip look for some baby ass no no you
you say that you you might run over a
baby
ha now you're thinking about babies
getting run over I'll just sleep down
here
I'm on my poo Pete okay I better do a
count of lines we all know the real
Russell Brand said so goodnight Fred
let's see B spend the night while his
father sends out the pink berets they
tried to track Evie down and I'm not
gonna lie these things are damn adorable
but that could be because they never
talked in comparison to this walking 90s
dad that forgets this all takes place in
the early 2010 I was gonna play extreme
pogs next it's wrong you look a bit put
out you've destroyed the place I
wouldn't say destroy it just getting
comfortable
gotcha kuzey loosen me right up
it looks like EB uses too many bubbles
in the hot tub oh and you haven't seen
this before you know what this film is
it's a bad school cafeteria of bland
seems you've seen a million times in
other movies okay you want that scene
where somebody gets messy and a lot of
bubbles there you go you want that scene
with two people arguing until they
figure out they have a lot in common
there she goes you want to be so boring
you'll forget it even entered you don't
get married
Fred decides he's had enough of Peter
cotton twatted decides to put him in a
box and get rid of him tell me about the
Lenny's George I click out we're
releasing you into the wild no no put
the bunny back in the box and throw him
off a cliff I wanna stay with you oh man
put the bunny back in the box oh hey
I'll clean up my mess
I'll do the dishes put the bunny
back in the box but no he let him stay
because he can do this what are you
doing
see jellybeans huh the jellybeans you've
been eating all these years are shit
shit huh so what so you talking you poop
candy show this to me you don't want to
know how he makes Lucy species bread
finally puts together that he's the
Easter Bunny you know he confused him
for all the other talking rabbits he
came across in his life why are you here
now oh just doing a little last-minute
recon for Easter deliveries finding
ideal egg hiding locations there's one
that's perfect this is trying to look
like one of those films you see mocked
in other films like they look real but
they're just too lame to actually exist
you know like George Simmons and Merman
or Jeff Portnoy and the fatties or Will
Smith in Aladdin I have a job interview
you were staying here but he's boring
just do me a favor wait in the car you
want that scene where someone has a big
obligation but a wacky character comes
and messes it up you were dropped work
you the Donkey Kong Country characters
are close by so EB hides in the building
where fred has his interview yes oh this
is great we already know how Chelsea
Handler also brand get along the way
you're looking at me makes me want to
cover up my vagina
they told her he'd be in a recording
studio yet she's still requested mace oh
are you writing a novel what's that
about a crippled soldier who in the
future goes to another planet and he
becomes one of the indigenous people who
are blue and live in the forest
that's not avatar not really that's
funny the actual pitch for avatar went
exactly the same way it's about a modern
person who befriends a tribe and finds
that environment is good but modern
people are bad that's not Dances with
Wolves Fern Gully Pocahontas and a dozen
after-school specials not really take
all their money cool how can you have
love foo and Prince Edward in the same
scene and not have them kiss I smelled
potential I smoked his nice tight grip
on you he'd be stumbles into a recording
booth that just happens to have a
completely blind band called The Blind
Boys of Alabama okay if there's any good
that came out of this movies that forced
me to Google this band to see if it
exists it doesn't bog god I want to know
their story but we get a CG sock monkey
playing with them and I guess that's
supposed to be just as gripping okay
it's cool seeing this kick-ass band play
but the scene is so awkward I keep
expecting it to be like a fake intro to
the movie a series of unfortunate events
you know the one telling you this
mindless sappy bullshit isn't the actual
film you're gonna watch
I'm sorry to say that this is not the
movie you will be watching the movie you
are about to see is extremely unpleasant
the boys tell me be that David
Hasselhoff is holding auditions to find
new talent and that he should give it a
shot
don't pull that with me rabbit okay
you're destined to do something great I
just know it you'll find an awesome job
hey remember when they said this was
gonna be about a man becoming the Easter
Bunny if they meant just sitting around
and talking in cars than Jerry Seinfeld
and James Corden should be looking like
Ralphie from A Christmas Story by this
point look what about this dog walker no
CSI officer no I think I used to be
quite lazy when I was signing on and
taking drugs the whole time though being
a drug addict can be quite taxing trips
get the money for the drugs then you
have to get both those things can be
troubling tired of boring shots of just
the two of them talking well don't worry
here's a crane shot of the two of them
talking we needed a plane shot for that
this movie's almost halfway through and
the imagine if Wonderland we've been
given it's on par with my dinner with
Andre the Hoff this place you realize
you can't talk I can no what I mean is
you shouldn't talk things Russell Brand
here is for 500 Alex but from now on
especially not in front of other people
they might freak out and what if I set
your brain I shit yeah we got to keep
this a secret while we eat in a public
restaurant by the window where dozens of
onlookers can't see you where are you
constantly trying to suck out what
little magic you have just give me
something anything associated with a
magical Easter Bunny movie critic
completely an Easter emergency oh my god
I'm on my way you must learn to play the
drums before the auditions for Pamela
Anderson's talent show this has nothing
to do with Easter plan better this isn't
even drums pleura like a drum play it
better
[Laughter]
hello husband
stamp you've been looking through my
phone what is the meaning of this I'm
sorry stamp I can explain
then explain you traitor you just don't
understand stamp you don't understand
stamps.com it's the perfect way to get
stamps hassle-free no yes no yes no yeah
why are you going to stand stud home why
there's so many reasons no one really
has time to go to the post office you're
busy who's got time for all that traffic
parking lugging all your mail and
packages around it's a real hassle God
but that's why stamps calm is so great
it's one of the most popular time-saving
tools for small businesses stamps.com
eliminates trips to the post office and
saves you money with discounts that you
can't even get at the post office
I said post office twice no yes
stamps.com brings you all the amazing
surfaces of the u.s. post office right
to your computer whether you're a small
office sending invoices and online
sellers shipping out products or even a
warehouse sending thousands of packages
a day stamp stock um can handle it all
with you know yes simply use your
computer to print official US postage
24/7 for any letter any package any
class of mail anywhere you want to send
no oh yeah what's your mail is whether
you just hand it to your mail carrier or
drop it in any mail box it's bad stuff
oh no
it stinks calm you get five cents off
every first class dampen up to 40% off
Priority Mail not to mention it's a
fraction of the cost of those expensive
postage meters no my goodness yeah
stamps.com is a no-brainer saving you
time and money
it's no wonder 700 thousand small
businesses already used stamps calm Utah
pay attention right now my viewers get a
special offer that includes a four week
trial plus free postage and a digital
scale without any long-term commitment
just go to stamps.com click on the
microphone at the top of the homepage
and type in nostalgia do it now no
that's dance comm enter nostalgia just
go this dance comm click on the
microphone at the top of the homepage
and type in nostalgia for your four-week
free trial
[Music]
[Applause]
so Fred goes to the mansion he's looking
after only to discover his sister is
there oh man she goes upstairs I'm dead
leave this to me awesome move a little
Wow Phoebe sneaks inside though and
pretends to be a toy oh oh okay that's
technically not a line but it's still
something Russell Brand would do I don't
think God would give you that body and
then gives you sort of morality oh my
god yeah when you laugh like that it
makes me know what you'd send that when
you come Fred puts him inside a Japanese
motel as his sister discovers his shit
beans don't eat that watermelon
it tastes ecoli ish but it's still
better than Harry Potter jelly beans
they go to the talent show where he
keeps he be hidden in a bag only to have
him come out and talk in front of
everyone this was written in a day -
relax I'll give you a good intro I'll
set you up and you knock him down yeah
yeah really mm-hmm thank you for it no
problem do you think james marsden meets
up with Neil Patrick Harris once a year
to share their war stories of working on
hop and Smurfs the compromises they meet
on Easter but they have to take a shot
of something blue
enjoy your meetups I know you need Oh
Phoebe performs in front of Hasselhoff
and he looks surprisingly composed
seeing how he's witnessing a bunny play
the drums how many drinks do you have
before this dad explains it I didn't
like it I loved it you want that scene
where a guy looks like he hates
something but actually he really likes
it haha Jake it never have kids okay
darling no you can't serve that no
special garnish
as they agreed on Fred got EB the
audition so he agrees to leave done you
a pop now I'm ready to get out of your
life but it's interrupted bite hold on
to your balls another car scene I know
we said we'd go in separate ways but
please I'm convinced the car is gonna be
the Easter Bunny by the end of this they
go to his younger sisters play but he's
afraid he sees the pink berets when it
turns out it wasn't them but he's stuck
up there so they pretend it's a
ventriloquist act and they sing I want
candy it sounds just as awful as it
sounds I might rather watch this creepy
man interrupt a children's pageant
rather than watch my child perform I
mind so much the look on Marsden's face
as he tries to maintain any dignity in
this scene is the same Margot Robbie had
an eye tania when things were exploding
out of control coincidence I don't care
it hits the air is this your new career
upstaging grade-schoolers with your
ventriloquist puppet no no no I got lots
of this stuff going on yeah I'm on not
supposed to side with the dead cuz I'm
really siding with the Damned can you
give me just one reason not to be
disappointed oh come on
he no not a thing this movie's terrible
I mean dim the little sisters say she
was really looking forward to it the
teacher picked her to be like the big
singing role they made an exception for
me on account of my singing and yeah for
whatever reason her singing sucks that
doesn't really make sense but why start
now in this movie regardless this
asshole still comes up and just ruins
her pageant and he doesn't make it up to
her anything she just has to live with
it and he's rewarded for some reason
this movie is just shit ha
you know what just hate everything
every but Fred gets an idea all of a
sudden wait is this for you to me you
want to see other Rapids cuz I'm
open-minded for it tonight it's just hit
me I'm insane and I'm walking into
rubber rooms so the moral kids if you
can't find a job you know be rabid EB
doesn't want him to do it though come on
Fred it doesn't make sense until a
moment later when he decides he does
I've changed my mind
we gonna do this well that ran the
emotional alphabet from A to A - insert
embarrassing grown man montage here Mr
Marston do you have kids don't they go
to school to live witness the pink
berets find the mansion though and EB
tries to fool them by making it look
like Fred cooked it before leaving him
to the slaughter what about friends oh
you'll be alright
humans can grow in their testicles back
right actually the more look at them the
more they look like officer Hopps and
this is cold hot what if this is all a
prequel to Zootopia cue critters can
talk they get organized they handle
Easter twelve Monkeys happens and the
animals rule the earth pieces were in
front of us the whole time we just
really had to hate this movie to see
them they bring Fred back to Easter
Island just at the time when Carlos
decides to take over
now eat them to eat them until their
insides are hollow EB gets ready to go
on stage where yeah I didn't think he
could do a movie without shoving his
face on screen it's a bait oh well a big
you want it onstage in two minutes
is this like Timecop where if they touch
each other they both explode can I see
that unrated version please
but the Hoff senses something is wrong
how's my little guy you're not ready for
hop and Hasenpfeffer with hop in Hoff
Fred could be in real trouble
no I find it oh he's not the jitters
David why is he moving like a
malfunctioning animatronic I find good
DB returns but the chicks attack him
that bird had the dead eyes of a
psychopath they are going to find body
parts in his basket
Karla's uses the scepter to transform
himself into a bunny
look there's actual focus on Easter now
I'll take it as EB has the brilliant
plan about winning the chicks by playing
the drums
remember that Aerosmith game where they
say musics the weapon well this is
nothing like that it's hop and it sucks
I guess getting the navigator to dance
throws off the chicks fly causing them
to crash I know what the so it's of
WordGirl that had more advanced
strategies but we pretend we're having a
good time maybe they'll mercifully end
early that I'm ready the day is saved
and this decided that both Fred and EB
will make deliveries on Easter while EB
continues to do his drumming by the
power vested in me I pronounce EB and
Fred O'Hare Co Easter Bunny's they'll
have an apartment in Boys Town sing show
tunes at bars and watch endless hours of
Antiques Roadshow
so Fred shows off that he finally did
something with his life he says he's the
Easter Bunny but I think he's Zachary
Hill Comstock building Columbia C
Bioshock is in the sky Zootopia is on
the ground it all connects Wow
I still think you're an asshole for
ruining my Play asshole it's nice to
know they forgave the chicks by
enslaving them for the rest of their
lives
one little cool
suddenly I'm everybody's Chum it's the
Civil War in Reverse I will not give you
a second happen this one Hey
I'm too depressed and that was hot what
do I think of this blam forgettable
horse shit
remember critic keep smiling there's no
smile we're talking about this film this
movie should have been a charming cute
adventure I dare even say it was
practically unavoidable a man becoming
the Easter Bunny promises a lot of
timeless creative imagination but with
each such of the first few minutes it's
David boring tedium nothing is funny
nothing is clever there's not even much
that's very colorful it's just pointless
musical numbers bland scenarios and
blase dialogue I hope more Easter Bunny
movies are made not so we can have more
like this but so they can help us forget
what is already pretty forgettable and I
still stand by the only reason anyone
remembers it is because it's the only
one when you want to see a film that
represents the magic and wonder of
Easter you can rest assure it's a
million hops and skips away from this
and you still haven't learned to play
the drums how do you expect to sit
around and whimsically do nothing when
you stuff stuff to do
hop to it I said the thing screw this
shit I'm gonna head over being Easter
Bunny to some Candy Man or something
excuse me did somebody say a candy man
you just grabbed this basket you wave
your hand in front the door and they'll
take you to the magic Easter place as
guy named carriages will fill you in
Thank You critic I promise I won't let
you down
[Music]
it's gonna do a good job
the prophecy has finally come true long
live eternal misery
mm sorry to interrupt I know you have
your hands full
you don't know where carrot juice is do
you oh I caramelized him over there
remember doc now I have discussed the
possibility of perhaps performing a
collage of hair a follicular structure
to join us all
hey Doug Walker here on the charity
shout-out this week is a little
different it's actually for a convention
but it's a different kind of convention
it's a free single day convention for
Chicago youth and also doesn't charge
anything for you to present there it's
called pocket con and the focus of it is
to kind of get more diversity in comic
books and artwork and so forth there is
diversity in comics and superheroes and
stuff like that but there's not a ton
this is something that's gonna put even
more focus on people that sort of want
more options out there so if you're a
person of color if you're a LGBTQ if you
have a disability and all this stuff
stuff that's in comics but isn't like a
ton in comics this is kind of a
convention for that right now I'm gonna
play a clip of the guy talking about it
here because he can explain a lot better
than I can so click on the link see if
you want to donate it looks really
really cool they died before he was a
big success
so go and check it out and here's the
guy that's gonna explain it a lot better
than I am
paka Khan is a comic book convention
that celebrates characters of color and
diversity within the comic book universe
we started off in the year 2011 and
there was not very much representation
of characters of color youth are always
gonna treat right then they're gonna
carry characters that they see it's
about making space you know creating
community and then when you go inside
you see a sea of people that look like
you and it's free we've never charged
our artists for tables we've never
charged youth for entry and we've been
growing a lot as we raise the bar that
means there's more expenses that come we
are being accident I'll pay for the
space if you are to donate little most
definitely help me out the next Super
whatever person of color that comes out
and has the biggest comic in the next 10
years could have been a kid that just
showed up the pocket con one day
you